all right let's go main chords guys
that's there better get on with the
starter gentlemen good evening
that's me Tom does it nicely max Harry
you four are a bunch of old Etonians
yeah and all of you think you've got
what it takes to work in my kitchen
god help me what's on the menu tonight
tonight we're going to do a crab spring
roll with some chili dipping sauce and
the not that we're going to do a venison
pan-fried with some yeah we're not just
cooking one table here we couldn't 14
okay don't let me down and more
importantly yourselves down okay guys on
order five cups of 10115 crap spring
roll five innocent five profiterole yes
no [ __ ]
never gave me I was not listening to the
first okay max come on in it come in if
you don't know listen you all and you
check on that right clear
good bye max and Tom's come over while I
put this one together quickly what's in
there Harry when we throw again quick
we got crab on Steve you got a sweet
corn we've got coriander we've got
spring onions gonna line up Snow Show
come on of you thank you that tablespoon
of grain mustard right let's roll one
together shall we
little bit seasoning on that yes and
then make a nice sort of almost like a
sausage shape yeah
just one third in up over nice and tight
and just pull back press down your ends
there Tom yes sir you look like you used
to roll these kind of things except
we're gonna fight this will not smoke
this one yes yes yes
he'll bit of egg white and roll nice
first table okay let's dress the salad
shall we please do no and they don't
work it's ripped holy [ __ ] what we're
just dying come on you watch me your
hands are shaking like mad watch that's
the customer they're facing you okay sir
come on let's go
yeah did you pay for them yes or no come
on good go please Table five go quickly
right that's the first table out there
yes
far too [ __ ] slow Ganesha yes now
that we know what we're doing can we
work as a bit of team so far your [ __ ]
let's go unbelievable this has to be the
hardest day work these guys ever seen in
the entire [ __ ] life
[Music]
[Applause]
I work for an asset management company
in financial services bit of an income
for a share portfolio that my dad
created
I love eating out a lot going out for
dinner imagine oriental hotel when I
spend less than 100 pounds we all went
to school when we're 12 years old to a
school called Eastern college and since
then we've known each other ever since I
love cooking because I'm the artistic
side of it getting your hands really
messy quite like to have like a starter
of cheeses
we'd like to fish fondue for main course
love fish it's expensive hello
adding my junus take one we're gonna
sell 150 based on it's as simple as that
we're never gonna win on order four
covers Table one full cap spring roll
for better support and fitter ah it's
really important you don't [ __ ] around
if I find you're joking and pissing
around I'd rather just [ __ ] off phone
okay it's all that all I've seen so far
a jumped-up little six-year-old wants to
play with his dick concentrate we do get
it right we'll have the [ __ ] fun
after it laughs no joke in in front of
them you can look stupid okay come on
guys please come on come on come on come
on this is [ __ ] slow rolling it taste
it because what your taste is what the
customers tasting yes we can't work this
slow guys yeah if you this though at
Claridge's yeah we're gonna be [ __ ]
you know huh at 9:00 table death descend
it's embarrassing come on just move your
ass showing
hello my darling hello thank you for
that yes now you have to be my ideal
gift love your food yeah now who cooks
at home we both do
Delaney is in charge of meat right and
I'm in charge of virtually everything
else
really vegetables and he's cooking and
the most amazing Sunday lunch you got a
leg of lamb yeah and he lies about my
producers yeah and you had that amazing
setup of comic relief where you exported
the sort of most handsome men across the
planet
yeah yes the terms of snogging them yes
yes George Clooney Brad Pitt Johnny Depp
you grant I frankly really good to see
you are an amazing kisser see you later
flavors in the sauce and in the spring
roll themselves pouch on anything I've
had to do a crappy book couldn't taste
the crab meat now in amongst the
seasoning of the mustard and
unfortunately once I put in a dipping
sauce it just was pure salt I've never
had Cornish crab so it was really nice
to try something different
quite okay results move starters yes
out of 50 guests yes
only 25 of them I'm paying yeah
why is her and just all too slow clearly
fattest hill yeah too much booster at
this one did you taste that did you mix
it I'm probably no every time no every
time you make a new mix you taste it oh
good
not good at all now I want you try and
put it back for the main course yeah and
get 50 out of 50 customers pain for the
venison let's go guys
next on the menu I get called out to a
fast food emergency though you just
change the [ __ ] babies dawn fan she
helps me in my search of the neck of
Fanny Cradock and I head to Norwegian
Lapland to catch giant killer crabs my
balls feel like two big [ __ ] ice
cubes
welcome back to the S word now close to
the main course loin of venison between
sour peppers and broccoli rabe
[Music]
loin of venison one of my favorite meats
slightly gave me absolutely delicious
public protein low in cholesterol and so
it's like the rolls-royce cut it's
phenomenal
I've cut it into four marinade olive oil
salt pepper thyme is a very sort of
dainty soft sweet herb and it goes
brilliantly with a rich gaminess of the
venison juniper berries the flavor is
almost like a sort of rich bittersweet
slightly peppery flavor garlic back your
knife on
get the loin place it on top olive oil
season
leave that to marinade and that's ready
for a pack
[Music]
cooking the venison he's gotta be a lot
more delicate than you worried you're
cooking a filler beef because it's very
lean hunting you fat on their hot pan
olive oil
keep on rolling around should become
nice and springy and slightly bouncing
and that indicates that it's slightly
pink a little bit firm in the center
butter face venison and then just take
it out of the pan and just spoon it over
there leave that to sit now for the
sauce will be a really nice sweet and
sour pepper red and yellow pepper just
stand the pepper up on its base and just
cut around like we're segmenting an
orange and look your seeds they're fit
to the pin olive oil in the pan a little
bit of salt and by having the skin on
the peppers it doesn't allow the
feathers become too soft and overcooked
it keeps them really nice and robust the
time this is where it gets really
exciting white wine vinegar it smells
amazing but it starts to glaze the
peppers I cut the tablespoons of water
in there but it's really nice sweetly
sour peppery vinaigrette at the bottom
peppers out carve nice thick slices
and look the juice is coming out of the
peppers a little bit of salt Just Blaze
the venison with some extra virgin olive
oil and there look venison with sweet
and sour peppers done okay listen I'm
gonna rouse you for the last time to
stop laughing and just take this next
[ __ ] half-hour really seriously right
there we go 30 seconds in how he's
pissing his pants okay seven five
venison hairy yes chef let's go let's go
right
gotta get hot yeah five venison in
you've got four in there sorry seven oh
dear oh dear
get some butter in there play here no in
there you've remembered nothing all
those [ __ ] stories they can't [ __ ]
absorb jack [ __ ] the excuses you guys
have come out with a [ __ ] hilarious
let's go hurry your pants on fire
thought we were doing put the pan down
turn the gas off first
holy [ __ ] take the venison out holy [ __ ]
really poor not be a collar on the
venison it's a delicate meat faintly and
it dries out of it to die come on guys
Tristen
what are you doing okay that burn now
then a kid
do you think I'm here to [ __ ] I saw
Joey go there but I won't come into your
world and tell you what it looks that
[ __ ] burn me chef could I also Hamet
our focus on the hand like that to
pepper and talk okay yeah come on let's
go mashed potatoes on come here please
Tom yes sir but I thought you cooked a
rack of lamb last I did sure but this is
venison I don't want to take these out
if they're not ready I love your [ __ ]
Arab you know that I've never met
someone so [ __ ] full of [ __ ] on my
corneas answering you backs not it we
don't know the dancer back about no
one's [ __ ] least I'm gonna pin you
every time I tell you something
it's like [ __ ] fight back fight back
what I do want is 50 customer service
that's what I want my kitchen my [ __ ]
rules
so far either stronger I need some
[ __ ] help right now everyone's the
[ __ ] argue and [ __ ] pity although
one is a customer sir that's nicely
cooked
let's go on there like that let's go
he's olive oil let's go
[Music]
trying to kill some giant crabs they're
big they're ugly and they're coming to
get us is the invasion of the monster
king crab king crab is the largest
crustacean in the world and a heading
for britain nor has a massive problem
with his huge giant king crabs
they're just breeding and breeding of
reading reducing the fish stocks and
causing a huge pocket
of the king-crab that come to England
are frozen
so I'm now gonna catch one to kill one
and see what it actually tastes like
fresh from the sea
[Music]
two flights and eight hours later my
landing token s where I met my local cat
hunter last petter I have to be never
been this far up it's [ __ ] freezing
here there's only one way to get around
in Norwegian Lapland and it's not my car
we're heading over the mountains and
down to the frozen thawed which is where
the crabs hang out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unbelievable
you get like a child again yes thanks to
my accountant until how I
50,000 crabs live under this ice and if
you want to catch one we're gonna have
to dive down beneath it did you ever try
me
I've never be nice dive you have the
lots of diving but it's a special kind
of diving and you need the skills but we
will try now don't make the hole too
small I want to get out easy just as
those [ __ ] things are huge I've never
died as I seen before that's one leg any
water get in there is the feel like your
big [ __ ] cotton bomb at least you're
embarrassing ice diving can be extremely
dangerous as it's so easy to get
disorientated in the freezing dark water
I'm [ __ ] myself when you fetch a
trap you should just grab one of the
legs the cloths are very strong so they
can't just snap your finger and even
yeah Maura if I'm swimming over one yeah
watch out for my wig yeah yes could be
cold down there before I already snapped
off
[ __ ] me is freezing we could get
hypothermia if we stay down too long so
we've got to be quick but that's easier
said than done I can see the crabs but I
can't see the surface these freakish
beasts grow up to six foot wide and have
no natural predators so it's dad's words
to bring their invasion under control
[Music]
[Music]
a lot Harden I thought it would be the
size of the thing just siting and look
beautiful my balls feel like two big
[ __ ] ice cubes
[Music]
Naza show me how to catch a giant clam
now we'll show him a new way to eat it
but first I gotta kill it
okay yep then it's dead
no it's clearly now yep yep we cut off
the legs
unball them in seawater for 15 minutes
discarding the body which isn't that
good to eat because the quality of the
king crab is so delicious it doesn't
need much more yeah so I'm just going to
do something very very simple with the
creme fraiche mayonnaise and some
tarragon yeah and some lime okay
I'm making the sauce by mixing equal
amounts of mayonnaise and creme fraiche
with some lime zest salt and pepper
roughly chopped tarragon and freshly
squeezed lime juice delicious nice
lovely you can try to break the mean
tight here in if you're lucky keep your
whole the meat will come up like this
lovely it's the size of a lobster tail
isn't it now look at that ah it smells
and looks amazing this is what I've been
waiting for
[Music]
after licious my god I actually now
think I prefer to lobster so much softer
and sweeter is anymore
what do I have to go back down and get
another one
[Laughter]
[Music]
too many men there is the sort of st. do
these world but let's be honest she does
seem a little less steady on a female
yes become a managed to get such candid
if passionate a lot of people think dear
very controlled
the reason why I'm sort of concerned
about the no one else coming I knew have
a quick look at this
look about bootiful yeah look then you
add a little 20 port I'm not going to
explain to you right now to load the
crowd chattering Roman look at candle
will you join up did you support each
other of course
one small wine glass from Tony book
that's the light then she was raw and
she was she was out there yes I'm gonna
search high and low to find a talented
female that's good enough to fill the
shoes of Fanny Cradock yeah and finally
get our own slot on the f-word I need
somebody with triple-a Fanning factor
you need discipline tenacious and some
of the love beating the crap out of
their top top Fanny right I know all we
have to do okay it's visit the website
and log on getting details and send me a
three-minute segment of show me that
they can cook understand losing money
factor yes okay would you my funny okay
alright
[Laughter]
I just thought the mate was absolutely
stunning it was well cooked
it was well seasoned and I'm never gonna
beat venison again because they don't
think that can be supported a very long
time for its curse to be honest the
thing that would put me on pain it
tastes very nice I don't think the
peppers are that sweet and sour but they
taste very good
okay was also the main course come over
Tom please yeah okay Tom how do we did
fifty-fifty okay
the dining room decided to pay for 34
out of 59 courses that means 16 refused
to pay why mainly the meat was Ray the
meat was dry yeah I'd like to think that
I stopped the rest of going out so I
think has a little bit of heart in terms
of 16 not agreeing to pay for it hey
listen it's not perfect but it's a
comeback on the back of the starters yes
yes I pictured that dessert 15 out of 50
okay let's go next on the menu I take on
at Attica Pinsky and the recipe
challenge
would you prefer top or bottom and Janis
reporter sings our teeth into Prince
Charles
now time for the recipe challenge where
I take on a celebrity and beat them at
their favorite dish ready yeah okay
well this is my father's recipe and it's
a tradition that yes you are except
since the completely household you get a
carrot cake made for you lovely now when
was that's how you made it
I've made about nine in the last two
days you're joking seriously it's the
first time another I don't believe no
serious first time okay in 11 years I've
made a cal fingers crossed right so I'm
gonna slip my dark brown sugar first yes
that makes a nice sort of smooth center
so it's not too lumpy we do two
teaspoons of cinnamon you must get a lot
of attention outside the newsroom yes
you do get the occasional in fact I've
got this one chap at the moment who
seems to every time he misses the news
he sends me a bouquet of flowers I don't
actually see that he's not that yeah
just sipped in my brown flour my mixed
spice and bicarb of soda
fold that in the oil the eggs and now
he's gonna add the carrot grated the
zest of an orange and the zest of a
lemon it's really important to keep the
carrot fairly wet that gives a really
nice carrot flavor I have mixed all the
dry ingredients in one oh and all the
wet ingredients in the other and then
basically you mix both of those together
add some carrots nuts raisins dates and
then
cake and now that you invited me very
politely into your okay if I just
quickly give your father okay it's
called Ramsay I've got an assessor in
the kitchen here and she's cooking your
amazing carrot cake oh yeah but any tips
in lacking confidence dad you're looking
at confidence I think a cracker would
yeah right your dad said move your ass I
look forward to joining your family now
that would be sort of brought in and
sort of given the cage sadly there's a
bit of bad news if she does lose she's
gonna start blaming you you were aware
of that honey
have a nice evening thank you okay bye
them green doesn't know does that make
you feel better yeah I'm feeling okay
now are you ready yeah yes off you go
would you top a bottom varnish right
it's a fact good food does it have to be
slow food I'm fed up with people eating
junk and using the excuse that they're
too busy to cook so every week I'm gonna
prove how little time you need to create
a delicious healthy meal
this week's six rapid response nurses on
a hectic 10-hour night shift for them
being fast is critical but their diet is
seriously slowing them down if it could
learn to cook something quick easy
something healthy and nutritious energy
right but we have a supersonic nurse
[Laughter]
freezer jam-packed yeah yeah we're sure
how'd you manage how'd you get through
your day courage microchips micro junk
you're being too much like women you're
caring for everybody power yourselves
challenge you could ask the guard yeah
by one portion of your frozen food yeah
come back cook it okay and by the time
you've cooked it and put on the plate I
would have had six portions of something
simple fast delicious with these two
girls do you are you ready yeah go jump
in your car don't smoke am I ready I was
born ready
the nurse II spent 25 minutes every
night buying ship food from their local
garage I am convinced I can teach them
to cook something much tastier sticky
lemon chicken set with champ and green
beans
we leave the skin on because gonna get
some color on the chicken that music
color means flavor
ready
hi how we doing for time for two ladies
are rapid-response nurses there's
nothing rapid about your cooking
you might just take you my pulse I've
been in here now eight minutes and you
drive around the [ __ ] bend actually
pretty impressive is that so it's not
high as good okay
now waiting madam is now things on the
way back cream and milk up to the boil
yeah and start stirring there my name is
in the microwave already I don't have
that [ __ ] thing will be a pepper on
there things out come on I'll do
anything by [ __ ] microwave look on
there like that okay right nice potatoes
on there you're telling on ice Lee now
that went well
Johan you being Jesus rice right place
being found the outside put the pan down
how long please Missy microwave Wow
12
sticky chicken with lemon and green
beads finish being look at that yes show
me show me the evidence on the plate
please
uh-huh as though you just changed the
[ __ ] babies yeah I've got too much
respect for your [ __ ] job for you to
sitting there no sorry no chance
fast food yeah doesn't need to be
complicating uh oh
chicken local supermarket feel better
honey promise me Sonny
yeah we're gonna do this again I'll help
you cook but I'm not staying to the
whole [ __ ] night okay guys let's go
lift up the button baby right finger in
I just put on top of that little point
there yeah that's not the point of birth
all right time to dessert profiteroles
with Chantilly cream and chocolate sauce
[Music]
perfidy rolls throwback to the 80s
something that we've all forgotten about
how to make the perfect choux pastry
first and foremost important turn the
oven on 125 mils of milk 200 mils of
water in to a pan it's important that we
bring it to the boil slowly butter
caster sugar salt it stops it from
becoming over sweet and gives a really
nice sort of rustic flavor to it off the
heat 150 grams of plain flour vigorously
fold that flour in back onto the heat
like that look beautiful just hanging
off the spoon cool eggs it's really
important to put the eggs in one at a
time therefore you get this really nice
incorporation of the white and the yolk
look beautiful
piping bag one nice lump and look just
coming through there she is there crease
through paper stop we can stick into the
tray down push and pissed away perfect
now
finger into a bowl of water and just
push down those little pointy bars this
stops your or from burning into the oven
18 to 20 minutes chocolate sauce we use
between sort of 60 and 70% pure Kerry
the better the chocolate the better the
source simple as there and the secret
now is to melt this chocolate whole pan
of simmering water that will melt within
three to four minutes butter honey just
look now that's beautiful
smooth and just this wonderful texture
there take it off the heat and that now
is perfect milk
out
creme Chantilly basically a really nice
flavored cream Isis sugar vanilla
and then mix it
nice piping bag
push in for the role generously fill up
you see the cream bouncing back at you
and just stick them together
lovely icing sugar chocolate sauce into
a jug
the hitter rolled with chocolate sauce
and Chantilly cream done
well guys the customers are waiting yes
come on and the secret are using fresh
minute of course it's a thousand times
more exciting than vanilla extract and
the flavor is extraordinary yes and that
yes you're a posh boy you should always
be using fresheners yes yeah good now I
use that quite caster sugar office there
yeah good all right guys stop making up
to break away plate up to back up please
let's go okay quickly come on fine
please yes right a question for for boo
yes while strong French was waiting for
her main course yes yeah her in a table
played shag or die which one do you
think one right be afraid that teeth the
back and the voice fast food I hates it
a Big Mac will never pass my lips I'm a
food snob there you are I've said it now
I've always associated so and sugar with
dreadful common fast food
until now when Prince Charles allegedly
called for McDonald's to be banned the
press claimed that his very own Duchy
originals range was even worse than
McDonald's but don't people believe it
so if you had a choice between a Big Mac
and a Duchy originals organic pie which
one do you think is the healthiest I
think this one if I said to you you
could have a Big Mac Big Mac never ever
okay Dutch originals
I'm confused and what to find out for
myself what Duchy food is really like
I'm going to Duchy supersize me and for
the next 10 days eat exclusively from
Prince Charles organic range well
Charlie tomato sauce fresh tomato soup
with Rose Marie organic parsley organic
sugar well sugar doing in soup sugar
fresh gravy obviously for clearly don't
cook [ __ ] gravy raw cane sugar
caramelized sugar there's no sugar in my
chicken and mushroom pie I can't eat it
I can't face it I mean my body is a
temple I can't stomach the thought of
another nine days of ducky nosh
so I'm handing the challenge over to two
younger fitter identical twins
to make things more interesting I'm
putting Lisa on the McDonald's diet
can I have a bacon egg and cheese bagel
please
while Julius shaft that she gets to
choose from the posh duck she range
[Music]
the twins will be attempting the diets
for 10 days during which time they'll be
closely monitored by a doctor and then I
discover that there's more fat saturated
fat in that pasty then there is in a Big
Mac this does contribute around 90% of
the guideline daily amount of saturated
fat for an adult woman that's an
incredibly large amount a duchies
Cornish pasty contains as much saturated
fat as forg in stirs Scotch egg bars or
three rustlers microwave barbecue rib
sandwiches or one and a quarter Tesco's
micro doner kebabs unlike me the twins
managed to stick with their menus for 10
days what I wants to know is how has the
Royal regime measured up to McDonald's
it was time to find out what effect did
have had on their health well remember
he thing is a cholesterol now it's the
same sort of news for both of you the
percentage of good cholesterol you've
got has absolutely dropped like a stone
I really
so the ratio good cholesterol to bad
cholesterol is now in the range that
would be potentially dangerous long term
in fact the cholesterol ratio of the
twin on the duchies diet had changed
even more than her sisters if she
continued eating her royal regime it
could have had some unexpected side
effects lost concentration loss of
libido all we can say is that in this
little experiment that we've done yet
with you two it has had a profound
effect on your cholesterol Yeah right so
I know [ __ ] up your sex life you can't
remember anything you kept putting your
phone in the fridge otherwise oh sorry
I feel old in a nutshell we need an it I
do feel bad about it
pretty shocking stuff but when I tried
to talk to Prince Charles about it he
passed it on to Dutchess who said
touchies originals are designed to be
enjoyed as part of a balanced diet all
our products use pure and natural
ingredients with no artificial
ingredients or flavors they clearly
state the ingredients and nutritional
content on the packets we are
considering adding nutritional
information on our website not good
enough Charlie I've decided to issue my
very own f-word ASBO to Prince Charles
for anti-social food behavior Prince
Charles this is what you've got to do
stop adding sugar to your savory
products
stop making products with high levels of
saturated fat and finally start giving
your customers a full nutritional
breakdown of all your products
I took Charles's ASBO to his mansion on
the mouth but he didn't answer the door
this is a special pie how I fine
considering I tweaked that stuff 10 days
no I lasted one day and you know the
reason why I lasted one day all the
ducks here there's no dock nothing to do
in my loathing in the monarchy no
nothing to do with the fact I couldn't
give a toss whether I get a night on her
not unlike you yes yes vote for one day
and I felt unbelievably all for free
sweets I might be tricky but I don't put
sugar in it do you pasty that was a real
[ __ ] body blood the company jet
capacity not very Janet
if he doesn't do what I've asked us both
I'm gonna go back to Clarence house and
I'm gonna post these bloody pies through
the letterbox next on the menu I've read
my own lamb I've come to Wales for a
shag and I find out who beats who in the
recipe challenge and the winner is
welcome back there for now here's the
news Natasha you're about to lose the
recipe challenge ready to finish yes yes
seven oh I'd love to know what you do
with your icing so I've always struggled
I use the Philadelphia some states
exactly abused nothing wrong with it
whatsoever okay I've gone for a
mascarpone one this time round so I
don't know whether or not that's gonna
work I'm Ryan's a piping hot palate
knife just gets a really nice thin icing
and inside the ice thing we've got full
fat cream cheese little bit of melted
butter and some fresh vanilla seeds
madam yes what no it's fine it's all in
the tape you tried very well now okay so
we slice a portion Jamie gently gently
gently gently gently
[Applause]
yeah completely different taste of isn't
it it's like it's quite syrupy as well
isn't it okay deliver the news yes the
good news goodness what are they say
then of it you know what this time
there's a clear winner right yeah yeah
and the winner is the winner is yeah
well done my patch news that's pretty
good to see thank you so much for coming
on now now one more thing yes
[ __ ] up out my kitchen now here's a
recipe for baby lamb one meal yes
[Music]
last year brought up two piglets trinny
and Susannah and they made damn fine
eating this year I'm taking homestead
farming to a new level
I'm going to breed my very own lamb I've
come to Wales home with the best lamb in
the world just three million people and
nine million sheep now one of they're
known as a nation of sheep lovers
[Music]
have stance welcome to Wales a big day
today
I've come to Wales for shag I'm visiting
an award-winning farmer whose family had
been rearing chic for generations mate
how are you see may has exactly what I
need to crossbreed my f-word lambs loads
of beautiful Welsh Mountain News he also
has a selection of pedigree French
Charolais Rams these are ideal as it's a
big breed and will give my lambs extra
bulk so these are these are
thoroughbreds I mean these are these are
yeah yeah French French yes Christ they
do look French so what we're looking for
in terms of I mean obviously a big pair
of bollocks yeah strength really yeah he
looks quite old you old yes his father
at all these offensive experience that
one are they friendly oh the fairly
friendly for the French yeah is that all
for the boys to drag down like that that
big yes yeah we'll have to check one we
leave to see if he is sure his bollocks
yeah to see if he's fit to work would
you mean well you're gonna feel they've
got to be the same size really balls yes
yes yeah I'll let you this is where you
come and it's not gonna start jumping on
their bollocks I'm gonna [ __ ] draw
the line massive absolutely massive
Jesus Christ
yeah they're hot they're balls
I mean they're like piping hot yeah [ __ ]
you so this is cool Jean Baptiste I've
named him John Baptist trying to get
your rocks off my man yeah Jean Baptiste
is going with mais Welsh Mountain News
these are one of the finest breeds in
the world and produce meat with a
phenomenal amount of flavor
Georgia Baptist why is he doing that
with his teeth he's showing off a bit is
showing his presence typical John
Baptist always [ __ ] flaunting it and
for him to lick you like that is that
normal
yeah come on John up teeth and he get
those balls swinging yeah he jackal
eight in that short period of time yes
yes yeah oh I'm in a second chance john
baptiste it's her [ __ ] French what is
it with them
Jean Baptiste will shag him left right
and center I branded the first two uz
covered in five months
they'll give birth my very own F word
lambs that will come home and live with
me in London bringing these two breeds
you know together it's gonna be quite an
interesting journey from Jeff's point of
view in terms of you know looking at
them both individually having tasted
them individually and now combining them
and is gonna be fascinating
is that absolutely or garlic it's got
any ordinary professor all is it no it's
kind of an extraordinary white guys come
and please yes right
starters yes yeah 25 out of 50 yeah [ __ ]
stuff yeah
Michael's 34 and pulled it back 34 out
of 50 now dude
desert well you did [ __ ] well yeah
you know
46 out of 50 customers Lisa listener
guys that means the grand total of 105
out of 150 yes what scares me about that
is the thought of you for right do me a
favor get to [ __ ] out my kitchen yeah
don't check your share prices